burrowed deep in the bedrock of  rialmonte sicily is one of the largest  salt mines in europe  and inside that salt mine is a cathedral  to find this holiest of underground  places you'll have to navigate 62 miles  of spacious pattern tunnels  concentric circles made 5 million years  ago from the evaporation of an ancient  ocean adorn the walls  lighter rings indicate a hot summer  darker indicate the cool of winter  and deep into these swirling pattern  caves you'll find a cathedral carved out  of the salt face by the mines workers  it comes complete with an altar  steps and a crucifix  800 worshipers can fit inside and the  space is consecrated in the name of  saint barbara the patron saint of miners  the salt mine itself plays a large role  in the local economy  and produces around 500 000 tons of salt  each year  but its value to the spirit  and the eye is unmatched  [Music]  you